doch wird präsentiert vom neuen toyota
rav 4 4 x 4 und hybrid die ideale
kombination für die schweiz
[Musik]
isabel salewa 14 jahre alt als sich ihr
leben völlig verändert
[Musik]
es ist schön so mittag sie und meine die
decke auf dem college breiter und jan
hat sich da immer so vor dem haus seiner
ex schalker seiner offenen verständlich
gemacht und stabilisatoren niedrig
vorwärtsgang und eine cd kaserne
brandbeschleuniger tritt bei und das
sind natürlich sehr groß ich bin gar
nicht sein auch von viel applaus
getrimmt sowie sowie erfasst und schmerz
gespürt dass sich fragen wo ich glaube
da ist zustand so dass kann nicht
bemerkt aber das kollektiv sehr gut
reagiert und mir das tool zeigt
und wieder haben
und natürlich ist da genau gemacht bevor
ihn ein
im kinderspital kam isabell sofort auf
die intensivstation und wurde in ein
künstliches koma versetzt
es gibt die hierarchie der probleme das
überleben ist selbstverständlich das
wichtigste das heißt die ganze
politische ausrichtung in der ersten
woche trunk nur sicherzustellen dass er
überlebt und dann in dieser woche wird
auch klar welche möglichkeiten man hat
in diesem eng bestimmt auch noch ein
gutes funktionelles und gutes
kosmetisches ergebnis in der
erstbehandlung schon zu erzählen und da
sind eigentlich die formation oder das
formiert sich innerhalb der ersten zwei
wochen und das ist für mein team und
nicht das schwierigste aber auch das
spannendste an teure dort wird klar wie
lange mit dem kind wie lang sie mein
lebensgefahr was können wir uns an
zusätzlichen operationen leisten um zum
beispiel ein besseres kosmetisches
ergebnis zu erreichen das wird alles
innerhalb der ersten zwei wochen klar
clemens schiestl leitet das zentrum für
brandverletzte kinder des kinderspitals
zürich mit seinem team behandelt er pro
jahr bis zu 30 kinder mit starken
verbrennungen oder verbrühungen
doch ließ verbrannte sich im sommer 2014
schwer der unfall passierte bei einer
ferien plausch veranstaltung noch muss
er deshalb tag und nacht einen
kompression sun zug tragen den
sogenannten jobs lebt erst seit
zweieinhalb monaten wieder daheim
regelmäßig muss ins kinderspital zur
kontrolle mit dabei sind pflegeberaterin
physiotherapeutinnen ergotherapeutin
psychologe und chirurg und das ist die
die er tag und nacht an nachts hatte
jetzt kommt wieder zu tisch kommt ok
jetzt waren wir an mit dem was ich
direkt ändert physio ergo hammer
besprochen oder und jetzt müssen wir mit
der anzug kurzreferat und markus dort
bestimmt immer wichtig weil die anzüge
in gewisser weise immer in schutz auf
die füße stellen oder das heißt würde
jetzt auf nur noch die hälfte von tag zu
tag oder nacht kann dadurch selber
entscheide reduziere dann sehen wir ihn
nach dieser nach diesem monat wieder
coco es irgendwelche verschlechterungen
gebaut und wenn es keine
verschlechterung gegeben hat wieder
anzug ganz weglassen
ich habe zwei sieht dann ist das der
schutz wo der zug darstellen
plötzlich sind alle plötzlich tut und
das ist für die einfach ist das
natürlich liebend ausstieg jetzt mit
unterseiten sowie interviews einfach
frage was das sehr schwer gemacht hat
aber eine zwischendecke lag ihm stets
vor der anderen sind und so und dann
wird es wahrscheinlich macht die
reaktionen hatte kopf schubst eine weile
nicht an mir also und die kinder haben
sich schon lange
kopfschuss gesehen also daher so ist das
mit dem gesicht schon okay okay also das
was wir jetzt tagsüber der anzug und nur
noch nach wir machen jetzt dann wenn ich
kein chips ihr habt und das ist nicht
überall chatel
ja es ist also es ist einfach so was
gibt es gibt diese hüte mit der breite
krempe oder die sonnenschutz teilen
diese schräg nach oben gehen die messe
stand rang direkt in der sonne und es
ist nur fürs geld es ist nur diesem
sommer so danach ein wenig halt dann
wollen wir dass es sich der sonne
aussetzt sondern dass es sich projekte
jetzt musste und auf 50 prozent seiner
hautoberfläche hat der fuß verbrennungen
dritten grades
das team im kinderspital musste viel
haut transplantieren
die meisten waren gesunde haut stücke
von seinem kopf und den beinen doch wo
dieses stück haut ist das ganz neue aus
dem labor ein hauptstück ist im labor
gewachsen
ganz ganz klar dass ich normal und das
ist zum ersten mal wird eine aus
patienteneigenen zellen hergestellte
haut am patienten verwendet seit 15
jahren arbeiten forscher und ärzte an
dieser hautkrebs nimmt an einer studie
teil
abschließende resultate liegen zurzeit
noch nicht vor
und darum isabelle wohnt bei ihren
eltern auf einem bauernhof in der nähe
von bern
sie ist die jüngste von drei
geschwistern ihr vater besuchte sie
trotz der vielen arbeit auf dem
bauernhof so häufig wie möglich
[Musik]
in der ersten zeit nach dem unfall
schlief isabel meistens deshalb brachte
ihrer schwester andrea ein buch mit
leeren seiten ins spital
die besucher haben für isabell
gezeichnet und gedichtet isabel ließ
sich nach dem unfall nicht fotografieren
deshalb sind dies wichtige erinnerungen
an die sechs monate im kinderspital
meistens an nur schwere zeit megafonen
theilig steuerlich absatzzuwachs auf
gesundheitsproblem kopf setzen einfach
wie jan immer mehr gäste das bedeute ich
mich verleitet und megaupload und nach
ich freue mich so hendriks berater und
einfach gar nicht es ist einfach so bis
morgen auf stangen ja soviel therapie
acker und tricks und sich auf sie und
lassen die akademiker und damit so viele
abnehmer des ärgers unterhalt das war
sehr schlimm sie und ja es ist einfach
sieht lang nur noch bergab gegangen und
hat das einfach offen
[Musik]
isabel musste unmengen an kalorien zu
sich nehmen wenn die heilung von
brandverletzungen verbraucht viel
energie
irgendwann camille kraft wieder zurück
es sei die liebe und geborgenheit der
familie gewesen die ihr geholfen haben
ihre schwester stand damals vor der
ausbildung zur primarlehrerin sie half
den eltern wo immer es ging zum
ehelichen
das ist schon schwierig sie aber
eigentlich ist gange die eltern von ruß
leben bereits seit sieben jahren
getrennt sie teilen sich die betreuung
der söhne cruz besuchte vorletzten
sommer mit seinem älteren bruder kuhn
eine ferien plausch veranstaltung bei
der etwas katastrophal schief lief
[Musik]
den genauen unfallverlauf wie die
familie nicht veröffentlichen
aus rechtlichen gründen die sind ganz
eingepackt das war die morgen für herz
und sauerstoff und da sind die
medikamente da war diese tournee
erschießt er aufgeschüttet
ich war jeder zu hause das schwimmbad
fühlen für die jungs eigentlich und dann
würde ich angerufen von die polizei also
kommt kantonspolizei oder kantonspolizei
zügig die mich erst ein paar von diese
probe frage gestellt haben wollen wir
die an was ist ihre adresse haben sie
kinder und dich natürlich ja also zwei
kinder zwei jungs was sind die gene
jetzt ich sage ja die sind bei einer
ferien plausch dann hatte er hat ja
gesagt okay sind sehr von ectr stimmt
dann ihre kinder sind jetzt bei mir und
wir fahren jetzt ins kinderspital zürich
also das war quasi wie ich das wie ich
das erfahren ab ja und dann gehst du
irgendwo in eine automatische pilot fast
im alter hin gestiegen zum spiel
gefahren
die mutter angerufen die von die kinder
natürlich die auch sie war sie aber auch
angriffe von die von die polizei ja und
dann einfach in minsk ist ein treffer
der älteste sohn gut sehen und dann
hören dass der andere in not ev ist
zwei tage lag lose auf der
intensivstation im künstlichen koma
zwei tage war unklar ob er überleben
wird
[Musik]
süß und sein älterer bruder kuhn
verbringen viel zeit gemeinsam sie waren
auch zusammen als der unfall passierte
chris wurde verbrannt kuhn hatte
unsichtbare seelische wunden
sie hatten keine möglichkeit miteinander
zu reden
doch cool fand einen weg mit einem
bruder der im koma lag zu kommunizieren
[Musik]
es kann nicht reagieren in den abend
gucke mir beim monitor gesehen dass der
puls nach oben geht merkt sehr wohl dass
der boulevard ist und fängt an zu singen
gehen da manchmal umgang mit dingen die
haben wir erwachsenen nicht mehr keiner
von uns würde sich getrauen
schnurstracks auf den patienten zu gehen
oder auf dem bruder zuzugehen der dort
im künstlichen koma liegt die hand zu
nehmen und zu sehen
[Musik]
der unfall von tamara schmid ist zwei
jahre her
sie ist wieder gesund doch ihre
versehrte haut muss nach wie vor gut vor
der starken sommer sonne geschützt
werden
tamara hat sich mit eineinhalb jahren
verbrüht das ist die häufigste
brandverletzung bei kindern in new york
als diener hat und wahrheit denn die
neckar war sind jetzt sogar mit lg
neckar-enz nach da weiß dass man minimum
aber heißt es wasser als die mehrheit
sieht zweiten ab durch die ich mit der
kollegin in der badewanne und handy
renault espace ist abzocke für mich ist
es der schlimmste moment
es sind weil die bahnen ist erstreckt
er wächst denn in arm des gordon guth
und der strait flechsig dass randy name
und mechanik wie man muss ja ab dusche
und das sind auch bilder wo bis süd wo
mich wirklich verfolgen
mit der ambulanz fuhren tamara und die
damals hochschwangere sandra schmid ins
kinderspital 20 prozent von tamaras haut
waren stark verbrüht auch bei ihr
mussten die chirurgen gesunde haut auf
die verbrannten stellen transplantieren
[Musik]
einem schwer brandverletzten kind wie
tamara müssen ärzte und pflegefachfrauen
regelmäßig die verbände wechseln
am anfang erhält das kind dafür eine
narkose die schmerzen wären sonst
traumatisierend
die wunden auf der haut von isabel salih
sind längst geheilt
die narben mehr doch bleiben
wenn isabell oder die leute geht zieht
die blicke auf sich
[Musik]
ja das habe ich gar nicht mehr blicken
jetzt haarscharf mit bedrücken
psychologe markus landolt und sein team
haben erforscht dass kinder andere
kinder mit narben als weniger
intelligent und unsympathischer
einschätzen
für die betroffenen ist es schon sehr
schwierig weil sie so negative
reaktionen amerika dort und und sich nun
also es gibt einer studie erwachsen aber
zeige dass die weniger also weniger
häufigen job bürger wenn sie verdienen
schlechter also es ist wirklich ein
nachteil der sich das ganze passiert und
wo eigentlich keine ist und wie eine
zusatzstrafe unfall oder was ihre kinder
führen
du bist jetzt heute kanzler sprach schon
zum schminken
es geht darum dass man jetzt mit zwei
oder drei aber je nachdem die ihn bei
uns genauer hut und reifen also der
bildungsgrad und den grundton und das
muss ich jetzt als die hälfte stellen
daher stehe mache ich zähle ich jetzt
das problem mit der erfahrung mit dem
doch das zusammenmischen business
quälend das bistum posten
ich will jetzt aus berlin jetzt hier mit
farbe oder für die post nicht so einfach
nicht verschreckt dass nachwuchs gleich
mit der bei den königsblauen und dann
sollten wir eigentlich da gab es viel
viel stoff es spricht dass bruni in
rötlich oder wir stehen natürlich
einfach mitmachen erinnert ja ok
[Musik]
roche fest dass eine seite zu schlagen
das match ist denn brauche so jeden tag
oder einfach so speziell
ganz anders das ist schon so dinger ja
es gibt nach edward demarco so
ungeschminkt bringt dass er die erst für
das der erste blick foto league nicht zu
haften blieb
[Musik]
isabel salih will brandmale und andere
haut auffälligkeiten erforschen
deshalb schreibt sie ihre maturarbeit zu
diesem thema und interviewt betroffene
und fachleute auch ihren kinderchirurgen
[Musik]
darüber haben wir immer wieder
diskutierten themen und vor allen dingen
haben wir mit unserer psychologen und
sozialarbeiter darüber diskutiert wie
kann man letztendlich menschen hilfe und
euch für die damit leben ist das egal
wie gut es letztendlich aussieht man
wird immer etwas sehen und man kann
diese stigmatisierung kann man den
betreffenden menschen nicht mehr mit
gewissem grade bleibt die wie geht man
damit um
ich war selber nach all diesen jahren
und kann mit kind und jugendliche
wichtig dass man offensiv mann macht das
essen dazu steht dass es so es gibt
immer ein ganz schmaler grat zwischen
korrigiert und akzeptiere ich glaube das
ist wichtig dass man in der natur arbeit
so zum beispiel these aufstellt dass ein
offener umgang damit
ja ich hab das ja ich werde an
gestaltete reagiere ich da drauf was
kann ich sage wenn ich gehänselt wenn
hier kann ich mich ja bekanntlich in
stark machen dass das ganz wichtiger
faktor ist
im um letztlich zu lernen damit
umzugehen sind direkte zukunft dass wir
heute in eine gesellschaft habe die
toleranz gegenüber menschen die an der
statik sind und ich glaube dass die
gesellschaft gut wenn sie diese
fähigkeit hat wir die menschen die
fähigkeit habe andere menschen die
lichter norm entspreche so akzeptiere
und so anzunehmen wie sie sind weil das
ist glaube ich das hat so viele
einwirkung auf unser zusammenleben
überhaupt innerhalb einer gesellschaft
dass ich das sehr wichtig einmal pro
woche muss raus in die physiotherapie
[Musik]
schläft noch
ja und schnarcht fußball laut ok du
darfst erstmal schlafen
danke
ziel ist dass seine haut den ball bleibt
und weniger operationen nötig sind
es hat keine lust auf therapie viel
lieber trainiert er nach neun monaten in
spittal und reha konnte hieß es kaum
erwarten wieder fußball zu spielen seit
einem monat darf er wieder mit seinem
team aufs feld
seine kollegen und der trainer besuchten
ihn in spittal und reha bei den letzten
partien fieberte ries von der bank aus
mit
[Musik]
die temperatur auf dem kunstrasen
beträgt 37 grad aber fuß hält mit
[Musik]
die narben brauchen viel pflege
damit sie optimal heilen jeden morgen
jeden abend zwei stunden pro tag findet
man die kraft um das zu machen und man
macht es frisches und damit es für ihn
besser werden auch nachher manchmal geht
es ihm auch wirklich nicht so war dann
hat herr salz satt aber wir wissen wofür
wir es machen und das gift gibt auch
wieder kraft und halt zu bringen
[Musik]
zum schlafen muss höchsten kompression
sun zug nach wie vor tragen
[Musik]
schneider nein nein
im hochsommer darf tamara nur kurz an
die sonne und nicht zur mittagszeit
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der mann darf
das stück wird die ganz frisch verband
immer ganz frisch
für mich ist im spital sind die bilder
immer wieder träumt ich hatte
unfallhergang immer und immer wieder da
und ich es immer wieder vor meinen augen
ist das heißt ich versuche immer wieder
zurück gemacht ich hatte unfall ich es
mal wieder durch gemacht und ich habe
sehr viel lauter schrei kann das niveau
nicht nennen
und dass sich emotional sehr anstrengend
sie halten auch in der nacht meist in
wenigen wochen das sandra natürlich sich
htc vorwurf macht
das klappt aber ich probiere immer so
gut ich glaube ihr versichert dass sie
kann sich keiner schuld dass sie nicht
das ist dass das ist einfach passiert
auch monate nach seinem schweren unfall
muss es immer wieder operiert werden
dieses mal ist es ein ambulanter
eingriff es darf am abend nach hause
wenn sich vorstelle einjähriges
verdoppelt seine körperoberfläche
innerhalb kürzester zeit zwei drei jahre
und dann mag die verpflanzt der haut
nicht mit russischen schulkind der macht
das nicht so schnell aber immerhin immer
ordentliche tempo das muss zum beispiel
im hals wahrscheinlich mit einer halb
deutlich sehen wir dass das sehen wir
vor der operation lässt muss noch seine
haut aus dem labor untersuchen
diese daten sind für die studie an der
er teilnimmt richtig
[Musik]
daher mache ich das ein bisschen schade
so und vielleicht noch nicht mehr danach
helfen
[Musik]
das super
aber die auswertung muss ich noch machen
würde
die eltern von rust teilen sich auf der
vater bringt ihn jeweils zur operation
die mutter holt ihn ab dies ist für
schließt die 31 station seit dem unfall
[Musik]
wir haben macht sich super alles die
ganze zeit aber ganz tiefen
so muss ich jetzt einfach noch ganz viel
luft und riss die wände muss
[Musik]
auch nicht
marlies sali die mutter von isabel wie
der unfall ihrer jüngsten tochter noch
immer auf vor der kamera darüber reden
kann sie nicht außerdem unterstützen die
familie grafe millimeter sehr viel
später auch sind sehr große
unterstützung und bin mega mega schätze
und ja von mir ist natürlich schwierig
also ich habe eigentlich noch mal in die
situation hineinversetzen sie seit
vielen jahren das versteht man wenn man
einfach schon mal tresen
ich glaubte schon sehr schlimm verdienen
doch das ist jetzt alles musste ja
machen und sie muss mit auftrag und sie
selbst einmal als sie machen es für mit
kollegen des rechtsamtes kurzum walter
und semir agenten verstecken ihre mit
ihrer musik auf isabel hat ihre freunde
zu einem sommerfest eingeladen
ein herzliches umfeld und eine liebende
familie
das ist für brandverletzte kinder
besonders wichtig was sie stört wirklich
jetzt abo zahlen oder die spots seien
verbrannt sondern als grund wird v wie
gott mich meine familie unterstützt das
heißt alle die familie unterstützen sind
was hinten losgehen etwas weg begleitet
der schwede sieht die sache hand und
vorteilen definitiv das war wirklich
bereit und darum machen wir aber alles
tun familie stützen
wir wissen durch klänge ist familie
entscheidende und der familie war das
nicht kann zeigt das wie vor bestehenden
konflikt hat oder wenn sie jetzt hat im
umfang zum beispiel
also fest weil es sich schon zu riesiger
nach halter und unser weiter geht wird
es schwieriger für kinder
sandra schmid hat sich für eine therapie
entschieden noch immer sind ihre
schuldgefühle zu stark es ist ihre
dritte sitzung 200 hz anfangszeit das
thema schule gefühl ist immer noch
aktuell
die schuldgefühle was ich dem unfall
hand wie sie das beeinflusst hat jetzt
im umgang mit der thomas thomas dienerin
dem sie sich gemerkt hat dass viele über
behörde ist auf nämlich passieren
ich hasse logica mit gepflegt dass ich
so gut oder dass ich wieder auf mein job
ich habe fehler gemacht wo zu dem unfall
führten ich muss jetzt wieder gutmachen
jetzt was mir meine sprache zeichnet
prozent dass man dank
und jetzt wird es im unternehmen mit dem
unfall wie sie da der schmutz machen
würde zeichnen wir das mal überlegt die
extrem schwer aber wenn ich sitze live
für den moment ist die pfarrstelle büros
gott der verschiedenen schulküche
ich sage jetzt relativ 20 prozent der
ganzen hof zu felde zu dass man halt
wirklich fähig sie sind unser nach linie
krieg ein dass man überhaupt auf die
idee sie zum der top 50 stellen und die
hochschule ganzen hof gezeigt dass der
teilweise verursacht hat man sagen sie
sich dazu bereit rein rational das an
traktion und geflügel oder aber dass ich
habe sondern immer wieder hilft wenn er
nicht so wirklich glücklich
die tür einen fehler gemacht so dass man
sich immer wieder bewusst wie mit der
schulklasse ausgesät oder es ist nur der
letzte moment wo die letzte hand immer
gemacht hat wird zu dem ereignis geführt
hätten dass ich eher ganze menge sachen
wo nur wenn sie alle der
liefersicherheit schlussendlich zu dem
ereignis geführt haben ich kann nicht
erwarten dass sie das ganze zeit und ich
weiß dank zu machen vielen größeren
größere teil wo sie als ihre stark sind
und dass sie das so lange heißt
eigentlich dass sie rein kognitiv rein
vom kopf her eigentlich das schon sehr
stark und relativieren es macht ihnen
immer vorwirft
kann jemand der einzige weg das zu
überwintern ist sich selber erzählen
dass das denkt man passiert ist und als
wissen dass ich relativ oder ich glaube
ganz abklingen wird die würde immer
sichtbar sehen und ich denke mir die
schule geführt werden immer dass es
wirklich besser
also hoffe ich glaube nicht dass sie
ganz
ich glaube wichtig ist dass sie das die
schuldgefühle soll es mag sein dass es
ihnen die ihrem lover jetzt groß wichtig
dass jetzt mal vorweg seien im umgang
mit essen oder mit sich selber oder
mehrmals pro jahr laden die spezialisten
vom kinderspital kinder mit
auffälligkeiten und ihre familien ein
[Musik]
sie sollen sich austauschen können
erfahrungen teilen wissen weitergeben
der familie von tamara geht es besser
seitdem sandra schmid ihre schuldgefühle
mit hilfe des psychologen verarbeitet
sind die alpträume fast weg
[Musik]
isabel schloss ihre maturarbeit mit
bravour ab sie möchte medizin studieren
im frühling wird sie ihr erstes
praktikum absolvieren
im kinderspital bei ihren früheren
ärzten
es hat sich schnell von seiner operation
erholt er kann sich wieder besser
bewegen
auch mutter josee ist erleichtert sie
hat nach dem erschütternden unfall mit
einer traumatherapie begonnen und diese
vor kurzem abgeschlossen
[Musik]
ich stelle immer älter war klar und wer
sein gerät und dann kam mir bringt im
juni zerschlagen konzept sei ja dann gut
schwieriger situation er umgab und ja
auch alles klar welches das knappe woche
schwierig sie und das ist einfach aus
ja und dann kann einem schon sehr viel
dazu gedreht was mir nach den
dachverband der schwere unfall hat
isabell sali zwar gezeichnet ihr leben
jedoch dominiert er nicht mehr
[Musik]
doch mit dem neuen toyota rav 4 4 x 4
und hybrid die ideale kombination für
die schweiz